All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
This one I got in many forms from a lot of
different people.
How the hell did Trump gain nearly 10 million
votes since 2016, given the disaster of his
presidency?
This is a really interesting one because there's
a couple of different angles to it now.
At the same time that there are people on
the left saying how on earth would more people
vote for Trump this time than last time?
You have people on the right saying clearly
there was election fraud because there's no
way Joe Biden would get so many more votes
than Trump had in 2016, never mind more votes
than Trump had in 2010.
So you do have people on both sides just looking
at the popular vote numbers and saying this
is something about this doesn't make sense.
The first thing before we even talk about
politics and and pandemic economy, all of
these different things, it turns out that
when it's easier to vote.
More people vote.
That's what we learned undoubtedly in this
election and when you had increased early
voting and most importantly, allowing in just
about every state anybody who wants an absentee
ballot to get an absentee ballot and to be
able to vote by mail because of the pandemic,
because of the risk of catching coronavirus,
where previously many states said if you want
an absentee ballot, it has to be one of these
rules.
You physically can't make it.
You're out of the country, you know, whatever.
We change that logically because of the pandemic
to be much more open to whoever wants to just
not go to the polls.
And it turns out that we were right all along.
The left was right all along.
There is a desire for more voting in the United
States.
Not everybody, not 100 percent turnout.
But if you make it easier for people to vote,
more people vote.
And that's not a particularly good thing for
the Republican Party, but that's part one.
So both Donald Trump and Joe Biden got huge
amounts of votes never before seen in any
presidential election.
Then the question becomes a political question,
which is given that Trump had his 2016 base.
And he screwed everything up.
I mean, he screwed up health care, pandemic
response, trade policy, immigration policy,
you know, we could go on and on all day.
How did he get more people to vote for him
this time around?
And there's a couple of different things that
that we have to account for know.
One of these is the answer.
Number one, the power of incumbency is a real
thing.
When we say it's hard to knock off an incumbent
president, it's because it's very hard to
knock off an incumbent president when you
are the president and you're flying around
in Air Force One and people are comparing
a president to a non president, that will
counteract a lot of the reasons that if you
were merely a challenger, people might not
vote for you.
This risk averse don't change horses midstream,
particularly for people who are not very politically
engaged.
It takes a lot more to get people over the
hump to vote to remove the existing president.
That's just a reality and that's a part of
it.
The other thing is there are people who wrote
to me.
They said, you know, one of the things that
happened is almost inadvertently, Trump lan
ran less and did less racist stuff in the
last six to 12 months because of his focus
on the virus.
I don't know that that's the case.
I mean, first of all, from the China Plague
Kong flu stuff to Cory Booker, black senator
will end the suburbs and minorities are going
to pour in and the suburbs, as you know them
all, stop low income housing.
There were plenty of racist dog whistles going
on.
But what is true is that there was less Hispanic
related xenophobia.
Maybe you could make the case Trump didn't
run as much on the wall.
Remember, the 2016 campaign was launched in
2015 on Trump coming down the escalator and
saying Mexico's not sending their best.
We're going to stop the rapists and all these
people from coming over.
Trump was less overtly about that because
he was very worried about other types of xenophobia.
And case in point, Trump did end up with a
larger share of the Hispanic vote in 2020
than he did in 2016.
So I think that that's a factor.
The other idea I have is could the virus,
as as disastrous as Trump's handling was of
the virus, could it have somehow in a backwards
way helped Trump with minority voters in that
there are many working class folks, including
those without college degrees?
This applies both to white voters without
college degrees and minority voters.
But Trump already had the white voters without
college degrees who saw, hey, this is a good
economy, service sector, etc. and it's being
shut down.
And I see Trump fighting to open it.
Is there some way in which that resonated
not just with Trump's uneducated white base,
with the minority voters without a college
degree?
Maybe so.
But again, it would all be merely by chance.
I think that that's the important thing to
keep in mind.
Bottom line, we have every reason to believe
that this number of votes really was cast.
Donald Trump did get millions more votes than
2016.
Joe Biden got millions more votes than that
and received more votes for president than
any candidate in history.
And we will be analyzing those results and
thinking about them for much time
to come.